il faudrait que tu me rendes un service
c'est là j'ai vu deux hommes de
Valentine là dedans ce matin ça leur a
coûté une vraie fortune
d'accord donc c'est du sérieux mais je
veux couvrir tous les risques donc on se
tient à carreaux on entre pas tant que
la directrice n'est pas partie dans
cette mallette il y a quoi au juste
regarde pas quand tout le fric que tu
veux dans les autres coffres je ne veux
pas te blesser
allez tout le monde artère on se dépêche
on y va 4 minutes on y va allez on bouge
on y va
[Applaudissements]
montrez vos mains tu gères on n'est pas
au bon endroit ils ont changé la vidéo
lorsqu’elles sont enregistrées dans le
Cloud ça n'a rien à coup à la va vite ce
sont des pros comme je te l'ai dit 50000
pour descendre unique
monsieur est-ce que vous m'entendez
monsieur Thomson je vérifiez mon pneu
j'ai senti comme Ta paix sur l'épaule
mais c'est tout ensuite c'est le
blackout j'ai pas entendu parler de Nick
si jamais trouvé son corps je pense
j'ai jamais fait confiance à ses gars tu
crois Jack et Véronica sont dans le coup
alors je vais devoir récupérer la clé
elle est disque dur
d'abord toi tu me voles puis il te vole
et maintenant c'est eux que tu voles
pour me rendre ce qui m'appartient facto
ouais ma de malette il est où
je l'ai vu une portée
des alors quoi
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je devrais te faire confiance
est-ce que tu l'aimes
c'est quoi ce bordel ce truc là c'est
marrant